claude avec un score en sa faveur aux
élections quelles pressions pourraient
exercer la première ministre des colas
sur jeunes sur boris johnson nikonoff
sur john est très déterminé et est
d'ailleurs très médiatique il est
probable qu'elle va avoir un très beau
score à ces élections qui ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui mais comme ça vient d'être
dit dans votre sujet il ne peut pas y
avoir de référendum en écosse s'il n'y a
pas un accord du gouvernement
britannique
c'est un petit peu la même chose que la
catalogne et l'espagne
et je ne vois pas boris johnson suivre
la voie de cameron qui avait décidé de
les premiers référendum est d'ailleurs
son parti le parti conservateur
s'ils en avaient envie ne laisserai pas
fait cela dit nicola sturgeon est assez
raisonnable parce que elle veut laisser
du temps au temps
dans le fond elle vit que lé partisante
d'un référendum mais pas avant l'année
2000 23
donc ceci laisse deux années pour
réfléchir et peut-être pour trouver
d'autres voies à 7 à 7 à cette difficile
à faire alors toi de la question qu'on
peut se poser évidemment s'il n'y avait
pas de référendum c'est pourtant une
promesse on le rappelle de campagne un
de la première ministre peut-elle
finalement obtenir de londres la réunion
cette promesse comme nous lisions un
instant ne dépend pas d'elle dépend de
l'accord de londres
il y aura probablement pas d'accord de
londres est donc en effet elle a des
compétences propres puisque ça découle
du traité de l'évolution et la l'ecosse
a les compétences propres en matière de
santé d'ailleurs elle a assez bien géré
la pandémie en main en matière
d'éducation et en matière de transport
et puis à des compétences partagées sur
d'autres sujets notamment en matière
économique dans ce qu'elle peut espérer
c'est obtenir des concessions du
gouvernement central en matière
économique et financière des
financements plus importants pour les
cos pour les infrastructures écossaise
par exemple pour liaison ferroviaire
rapide entre l'écossé londres et un
certain nombre de sujets de ce genre
mais le
la question de la dépendance
naturellement restera restera sur la
table merci claude blanchemaison
direction rt france